so the question is whether India can
become a single file I think undoubtedly
yes we have everything going for India
both in terms of a strong mandate with
the strong government in the near term
demographics the democracy the language
skill sets the innovation the service
provider of choice to hear develop the
world I think what will hold us back
will be our weakness in implementation
our demo demography if not educated will
turn back on us which is something we
need to clearly focus on education
healthcare all these critically not
dealt with and kept to the last will
turn India into this of a super power
can be otherwise i would say as far as i
know if things work out and the level of
optimism and we kept to a mid-level
certainly more certain